bindi Irwin trades in her khakis for  some fridge  so dog spotted the Dancing with the  Stars competitor on set in a dance  costume for the first time rocking  crystals and fringe for what we can only  assume was a promo shoot for the ABC  shows of coming season come on out bindi  Irwin bindi was the first celebrity  competitor confirmed for Dancing's 21st  season sent to premieres September 14th  and she told GMA shall have to warm up  to wearing the show's over-the-top  costumes I'm used to cocky and boots and  I think it'll always be a part of my  life I mean we always say khakis not  just a color it's an attitude but we're  sure bindi you will rock it  earlier this year she told me she's are  ready to take on Hollywood I'm excited  for everything that you have to come